think it's like women we don't want the
it's like the biological reason is we
don't want the resources to go to
someone else so that's like why if a
girl catches it like a guy cheating it's
like do you love her where if a guy
catches a girl cheating like don't guys
ask like where they slept together and
all this stuff
like was was he big or was he I mean I
don't no I've I've never been in that
situation you'd be more okay do you
think women would be more okay with two
wives rather than just a man that
constantly as like is I mean what do you
think would be better for women I mean I
think the two wives would be better but
I think modern women are Sideshow I
think modern it's like situation chips
and what's a situationship you're
sharing a guy